SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: It's been
about, I think 15 months-- wow,
time flies-- since we launched
a separate section in the Play
Store just for families.
And since then we've built a
lot more products and services
for this audience.
So I'll share some of
those things with you,
as well as insights on what
we have sort of gleaned
from this 15 months of stuff.
So families are a very important
and strategic audience,
and we all know that, right?
And they're both important
and strategic to Google,
but also especially to Play.
Most of the families, most
of the world's population
lives in family-based
households, right?
And as we can see,
just in the US alone,
the family, the
device usage, both
for smartphones and
tablets, is much higher
in houses which
have minor children.
In fact, those households
also-- their families
tend to use their mobile devices
a lot more for purchasing goods
and services or playing games.
And it is not just
the sheer numbers
of families that matter here.
It is also how they
use technology.
We've done a lot of surveys
of parents and kids,
and in fact, overwhelmingly
kids say technology
is a part of their life.
And it's one of the best
parts about being a kid.
And one such kid is Mattheus,
who is a 10-year-old in Canada.
And he loves Rubik's Cubes.
And he's using technology
to create a contraption
to help him solve Rubik's Cubes.
And it's just one example of how
kids, and therefore households
that have kids,
really experience
technology in a different way.
And that's why we
created experiences just
for families in the Play Store.
So as I said last year,
about 15 months ago,
we launched a separate
destination on the Play Store
just for families.
And then in a
major store update,
we brought that
front and center.
So on the main
store, users can just
click-- parents
can click on that
and basically see all
the content for families.
At the end of last
year, we launched
a family music plan where up
to six members in a family
can share purchased
music for $14.99.
And when you think
about stuff that you
want to share with families,
or do with families, right,
there's a lot of
sort of exploring,
learning new things together.
You know, I know with my kids,
I love cooking or traveling.
You want to make
sharing really easy.
And that's why a
couple of months
ago we launched
the Family Library.
And what this does is allows
you as a family, again,
up to six people, to
share purchased apps
and games, movies,
TV shows, books,
with members in your family.
And from a developer
perspective,
what this does for you is,
it increases your engagement
and reach.
And for users, it gives
them a great experience
as a family on Play.
And one of the best
parts about this
is when someone is setting
up that family account,
they actually put down
a family credit card
as a family form of payment.
And as we all know, that's
one of the biggest hurdles
or friction points
in the purchase flow.
So now that they have
it in there already,
they are more prone to
hopefully making purchases.
So now let's shift gears.
We're talking about what's
important to families.
What content do families
care about, right?
And as all of us who
are part of a family
think about, one thing I
think remains constant,
no matter where you are--
developed world, emerging,
rich, poor, rural, or
urban-- most, you know,
parents want to raise their
kids to be happy, productive,
successful.
And how do we help them do that?
So, anyone know kids who
are starting school now?
It's the back to school season.
Which year are they going to
be graduating from college?
Quick math here.
2033.
And I guess depending on
how many years of school
there are, but at
least in the US, 2033.
And you think about, what
are they going to be?
Yes, they'll be doctors, they'll
be scientists, engineers,
what have you.
But research shows
60% of those jobs
have not been invented yet.
So then here's the conundrum.
If there are jobs that
haven't been invented,
and technologies
haven't been created,
and we don't even know which
problems we're trying to solve,
how do you help
these kids grow up?
How do you use technology to
help them be happy, productive,
successful?
Right?
So one thing though, is always
good to know and reassuring
with all this uncertainty,
kids will always be kids.
Which means they will
be insatiably curious,
and that is really helpful,
as you know, they need to be.
So as we start thinking about,
as parents, as educators,
as developers, as you
know, the whole community,
how do we prepare
this next generation
for those challenges,
and how can technology
play a role in that?
Google commissioned the
Economist Intelligence Unit
to do a survey to
understand what
are those skills that those kids
will need for those jobs that
don't exist today.
So I'd love to get your
thoughts, any thoughts on kind
of what came up.
And by the way,
feel free, I want
to make this more interactive.
And [INAUDIBLE] ask
a lot of questions.
Anyone?
There's no wrong answer.
Travis, can I call on you?
Any thoughts?
What skills would be
important for kids to learn?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
creativity.
SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: A
good answer, yeah.
Creativity is important.
Anyway, so you know, there
are-- so interestingly,
one would think that, yes,
coding and engineering
and all that, the sciences
and all are important--
and they were there.
But business leaders
overwhelmingly
said the soft skills
are really important.
So you know, problem solving,
team building, collaboration,
communication, all
those really matter.
And why?
It's because even as technology
changes, types of works people
do are different, and again,
those jobs, 60% of which
haven't been invented yet.
These skills are what you
need to basically crack
hard challenges, right?
Work with diverse
teams to solve problems
or imagine problems
that don't exist.
So as developers,
think about making sure
that the apps and
games you build
help instill these
skills in kids,
more than just, it's a math
app, or this app helps them
with this particular
part of their curriculum.
So innovation-- so I'll give
you some examples of these,
even at Google-- innovation
we know is global.
And as we think about
innovation in the future,
it's going to come from a lot of
different perspectives working
together.
In fact, we have human
to human collaboration,
and there's a lot more human
to smart machine collaboration.
So at Google, we
have a diverse team.
And you can see
just being here, we
have people different
countries and cultures
and different languages
work together,
but also collaborate
across disciplines.
So for example, you
have the Google Lens,
which is a contact lens,
which measures the blood sugar
level in diabetic patients.
And in this we have, of
course, data scientists,
computer engineers, but
collaborating with biologists
and urologists, right?
So a more recent example is
the phenomenon of Pokemon GO.
You've got IP licensors and
AR engineers and cartographers
all coming together to create
this really interesting,
different experience.
So to do well, kids
will need to learn
how to collaborate effectively
across all these boundaries.
And creativity, as
Thomas mentioned also,
is going to be really important,
because creativity actually
drives true invention.
So think about
artificial intelligence,
for example, where you
have, in Google Photos,
you can do a search for
pictures of your dog.
And without having tagged
them, all the pictures
in which your dog
is present show up
because it understands the dog.
Or the technology in
self-driving cars, right?
Industrial machines took
over blue collar jobs,
and we see computers
increasingly taking
over white collar jobs.
But there's something computers
won't ever be able to do,
which is identify
what are the problems
and what things need
to be created, and then
drive to create them.
And that is why helping kids,
instill creativity in kids,
is so important.
There's a lot of information,
right, at our fingertips.
And in fact, years ago
kids went to the library
and sifted through encyclopedias
and got that information.
Now they have it on a
computer on their desk.
Then they have it
on their phone.
They have it on their wrist.
And soon they're going
to be wearing things
which give them information.
So critical thinking is really
important to understand,
with all the sea of information,
how do you sift through it,
find out what's important,
and then actually use that.
So moving on now a little
bit to kind of our learnings
from having the families
actually on Play,
and what it takes to
achieve success there.
So we've done a lot of
research, as I mentioned,
with parents and kids.
And as you all know,
there's two main users
of any kids' content, unlike
sort of other categories.
So you've got the parents
who made the download
decisions and control the
spend, definitely, and who
also monitor the usage.
And then you've got kids,
who are the ultimate users
of that content.
And we've seen this
distinct split.
As kids grow older, the
parent's role changes.
So when kids are young, up
to eight years old or so,
parents really make the ultimate
decision on what to download.
They have the final say.
They make the decision.
They, in fact, for younger
kids, they spend a lot of time
with the kids, and you
know, playing with them
with that content.
But as kids grow older,
their interests change.
And they get their own
hobbies, their own friends who
will give them
recommendations, and they
have their own devices.
And that's where parent's
role changes more
towards this sort
of monitoring role,
and sometimes this is
where parents and kids
butt heads on what's
appropriate to download.
So therefore,
thinking about parents
is equally, if not
more important,
as thinking about kids.
So on Play, we've
noticed parents actually
browse a lot more
than the average user.
Typically, people
come to Play Store,
they know what they
want, they search for it,
download and leave.
But when parents do
that, they actually come
and they spend time
browsing, looking for stuff
that they think their kid is
going to be interested in.
They spend a lot of time doing
categorical, sort of searches,
and going through
different categories.
And also comparing apps
and evaluating them to say,
is this appropriate
for my child.
And when they search and
browse, what do they look at?
There are three main things
that they've told us.
They care about brands because
brands to them denote quality,
and it's appropriate, it's kid
friendly, and especially brands
that they've known and loved.
And so investing in a
brand, while expensive,
definitely makes
sense in the space.
They also think about interest,
their child's interest.
A child likes dinosaurs
or planes or travel.
And also sometimes
formal learning,
you know, the math, animals.
And then finally, they
care about characters.
And they care about
characters that
are-- kids are
watching their TV shows
and [INAUDIBLE] interested in.
But also even sometimes
characters from their childhood
that they want to
bring to their kids.
And what are the top
factors that parents then
use to make their
decision to purchase?
So the million dollar, or rather
the $2.99 question, rather.
So they've told us these six
things matter a lot to them.
Fun and engagement
is important, right?
And that makes sense.
But this also, there's
a nuance to this.
Because this changes as
the kid's age changes.
When kids are younger,
parents are looking more
for something
educational and fun.
But as kids grow older and
they start going to school,
parents recognize
they're getting
a lot of learning from there.
So then it becomes more
entertaining and recreational.
So it really needs to be a
way for them to relax and not
kind of to get stressed out.
They also care about it
being age appropriate, right?
So this is not just
the content, you know,
doesn't have profanity or
sexual content and all,
but is my kid going
to be frustrated
because the activities are
too easy or too hard for them.
So really look for that.
They care about interest,
and we've talked about that.
And this is where
sometimes for older kids,
their interests and their
parent's interests diverge.
And educational
content, and this
matters a lot when
they are younger.
Because for younger
kids, parents
associate any sort of content
with being educational.
High quality really
matters to them.
Like it needs to be something
that looks professional,
it's been done nicely.
And then, of course, price.
So how, where do
they look to know--
I mean, that's a lot
of huge laundry list--
how do they know that
something has this or not?
The app listing page.
And that is why it's
really, really important,
and as you've probably heard,
a lot of the stuff we're doing,
all the tools Google
Play is building,
are geared towards
really helping
you guys optimize that page.
Right?
So here, star rating matters.
And star rating, four stars
or above is really good.
And what parents say they
do is when they even,
in search results, they use
the star rating as a way
to then click into and
get into a listing page,
because they're like, wow, this
seems like it's high quality.
And we've seen
before also, quality
corresponds commensurately.
The higher the star
rating, and also
corresponds to higher revenue.
Parents also use the family
badge with the age rating.
And that, they've told us, is
a really quick and easy way
for them to scan to see, is this
trusted and appropriate, right,
and kid friendly, and also is
it appropriate, age appropriate,
for their kids.
So that badge is
really important.
So as you think about what
age group you want to,
you want to put
down for your app,
really think
carefully through what
is that, what that
is, because parents
will use that to
determine whether
or not to download your content.
Title and description matter.
In fact, parents have
told us they actually
read the description
fully, and probably more
than any other category.
So make sure you are very
thoughtful when you're
writing that description.
And I've said before
in other presentations,
you know, if you want accolades,
and all that's important,
but really be very clear upfront
initially, this is what it is,
right?
And then you can go through all
the different prices and all
[INAUDIBLE].
And finally, icon and
screenshots are very important.
Kids especially react,
and we've done surveys,
they react to the icon.
That's one of the most
important things for them.
And parents use screenshots
to understand what
the user experience will be.
Remember, they're not
the ultimate user.
And especially for something
that they're not sure of,
the screenshot tells
them very quickly,
yes, this is something
that my kids would like.
Ratings and reviews, you've
heard a lot about how important
they are in having a,
sort of, in improving
your quality of the app.
And it reflects--
sorry-- it reflects
in the quality of the app way
more important in this space,
family space, than any other.
Because parents use these
reviews to understand,
is that content appropriate,
have other parents
liked this content.
And it gives them
a sense of whether
or not their kid will like it.
Remember, because they're making
a decision not for themselves,
but for someone else.
So the first, typically the
first ten reviews or so matter.
And it also matters,
are those reviews
from other parents, right?
Because even if it's
friends who don't have kids,
it's not as important as
someone they don't know,
but who has a kid
their kid's age.
So they really look for
reviews from other parents.
And I'd encourage
you guys to make sure
that your users who love your
apps leave reviews up there.
And take advantage of
Play's features and reviews
that you've heard about
earlier today, and also at I/O.
So we talked about how
compelling store listing is,
and the icon.
How many people here have used
store listing experiments,
by the way?
How many haven't, but plan to?
OK.
Well, these are
really important.
You've heard me
talk about, probably
if you've come to one of
my presentations, Rovio,
who now does not launch
anything without experimenting
with the icon to see what works.
And then BabyFirst, who
used-- changed an icon
and saw a 10% increase
in installs in their app.
And some of you
earlier this year
may have heard Per
from Apps Families,
talk about Superpuzzle.
They noticed when they launched
with the dragon icon wasn't
getting a lot of downloads
and they weren't sure why.
They changed to the unicorn
and almost immediately
revenue and downloads doubled.
And they figured out,
it's because there
are a lot of moms who
are downloading this.
And for some
reason, I think they
saw women get, like the
icon, like unicorns.
And so then after
that, they experimented
with using a borderless
icon, and they saw installs
increase up to 5% after that.
So if you're not
using this already,
I would definitely
think about this.
But the point I'm also
trying to make here
is, think about your audience
and what they want, right.
They're thinking
moms are downloading,
unicorns matter to them.
And then test it.
So this is where it's
both an art and a science.
So a high quality experience
needs to work on any device
that it's used on.
And in the kids
space, tablets are
way more important than in
maybe any other category.
And in fact, I would say
equally, if not more important,
than phones.
So younger kids especially
are avid tablet users.
Sometimes it's a cheaper device.
It's a hand-me-down
from their parents.
It's a family device,
unlike the phone, which
is a very personal device.
And given that, a lot of
spend are family apps.
A majority of it
comes on tablets.
Optimizing for tablets and
using our tablet guidelines
to make sure that you
use the full real estate
in your screenshots,
and using as much
as you can to make sure it
works on tablets is important.
And then speaking of
testing, right, you
want to make sure that it works
on whatever device, as I said.
Whether the parent or the
child making the decision,
it needs to, you don't
want them to leave--
you've got this
beautiful content that's
teaching kids creativity
and collaboration--
but if it's buggy,
kids are fickle.
They're going to leave.
So use-- and I know we've
talked about this earlier--
but use the Firebase Test
Lab pre-launch report to see,
does it work on all the
devices it's supposed to.
Are the screenshots showing
up correctly where they are?
Are there any bugs
or vulnerabilities?
But I want-- you
know, I've done a lot
of talking-- I want
to also for you
to hear from developers
on what Play for Families
has meant for them.
Can we play the video, please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The launch of the Family
section on Google Play
was hugely positive
for StoryToys.
I think what it did
was solve the discovery
issue for parents.
It's really provided a safe,
trusted, creative space
for families to
find new content.
- My partner, Guy Oranim,
and I started BabyFirst
with the idea and the passion to
create good educational content
for babies, toddlers
and their parents.
When we learned about
the Family category
on the Google Play
Store, it was 100% match
to the BabyFirst values.
We have seen that
parents can easily
find the content
they are looking for.
We now have 40% more
downloads on Google Play
than we do on other platforms.
We like that.
- Since the launch of the
Family section on Google Play,
our experience with Android has
been completely transformed.
We saw a huge uplift in
revenues, and of downloads,
too.
Google Play was now
our number one channel.
It's been nothing but
positive, and we're
delighted to be involved.
[END PLAYBACK]
SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: That's
what I want to close with.
So if you are-- we talked about
a Designed for Family Program
earlier-- so if you are
building any content for kids,
either if it's purely
for kids, i.e.,
child directed, or it's
for a mixed audience,
so adults and kids
both enjoy it,
make sure you join the
Designed for Families Program,
understanding the guidelines.
So you need to have a rating
of 10 or 10 from ESRB.
And also think
about the audience,
where if it's a purely
child directed app,
you can't use
Google Play sign in.
And if it's for both kids
and adults, you can use it
but make it optional.
For the rest of you,
if you're thinking
about creating
content, both for kids
and publishing on
the Play Store,
definitely download that.
Our marketing team has
done an amazing job
in getting, not just insights
that we've learned on Play,
but also insights from other
developers, some of which
you heard in the video, on
best practices that they use.
Cool.
Thank you so much.
And I'll be around later if you
want to ask any more questions.
Hope that was helpful.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]